they are considered the voice for the
children in clark county placed in the
foster care system
today about two dozen casa volunteers
sworn in to help meet the need in
southern nevada
christian kosovo is joining us live from
our newsroom with more on who these
advocates are
brian during the virtual ceremony judge
sullivan said these are very
important roles they consist of a former
law enforcement officer
and fire department employee also a
teacher and a unlv
student so tons of variety there now the
new group of 20 volunteers started their
two-year commitment
in a virtual ceremony where judge frank
sullivan appointed them
to best advocate for the interests of
the children overall 52 minors will be
assigned
to the court-appointed special advocates
better known as casa volunteers
now the program began in 1980 and it
currently has
386 volunteers but they're looking to
increase 13 to 1 000.
they will be working with abused or
neglected children right here in clark
county
and according to judge sullivan their
main role will be to report what the
child's goals
look like we get a lot of reports from
department family services
they are the case managers responsible
for taking care of our children and
child welfare system
their reports are very cold in the sense
they just kind of give us the facts the
counseling the kids are going through
the issues they're having how the
family's doing but they don't give us
the essence of that child the constants
give us the essence of that child
what their child likes what their child
hopes what their child's dreams is
well it was a very exciting and
emotional day as you can imagine each
volunteer was sworn in today and was
recognized individually
they will help get each child in the
system out as quickly
as possible now judge sullivan added
that once a child gets connected with a
casa volunteer
they will get a voice in the system
which ultimately means a future
so congratulations to all the 20 new
volunteers christian casadas 8 news now
and we echo that congratulations thank
you christian